all right this is really a good one even
Fox News host Larry Kudlow is now saying
to Republicans it really doesn't seem
like you have evidence that Joe Biden
committed any crimes the example we're
going to look at is from yesterday this
is Larry Kudlow talking to Republican
Senator Ron Johnson remember that the
context here is that they supposedly
have a whistleblower or informant or an
informant on a whistleblower with
evidence of Biden crimes
they or he or she is missing they quite
literally they said we don't know where
the person is and it's all just a comedy
of errors and now even on Fox News Larry
Kudlow is like you know you don't really
seem to have the evidence and Ron
Johnson goes with a classic conspiracy
line which is the lack of evidence is
the evidence because it proves that the
criminality has been covered up this is
a classic among conspiracy theorists
listen to this folks this is just just
embarrassing for these people
Biden himself as vice president and
maybe as president has not yet been
clearly fingered uh the so-called he is
that's actually that's correct
they I mean they're trying they're
pointing but there has not been a
successful fingering of Joe Biden that
Cal Kudlow is willing to admit it good
for him and maybe his president has not
yet been clearly fingered right uh the
so-called bribery allegations pay for
play by national affecting some kind of
uh policies hasn't that last step or two
Senator Johnson we haven't really
fingered him and I don't know how
important this informant is inform it I
don't know if there's anybody else that
could do it but it seems to me that's
going to leave a very big Missing Link
yes called evidence well we mean all the
bank records I know James Comer hasn't
been able to get all the bank records
but let's face it criminals hide their
criminal activity ah they don't make it
easy for people to uncover their
wrongdoing and so these investigations
are are painstaking you've got to you
know pick up one piece of evidence and
try and follow that thread to the next
piece and again when you've got a
complicit and corrupt media that won't
report the truth that shows in terms of
all the evidence we already do know of
the corruption of the Biden family right
but we still like this guy president and
they're still covering up for him it's a
real issue that's a sitting Senator
casually referring to the president of
the United States as a criminal absent
any evidence whatsoever and listen to
what he said the lack of evidence is the
evidence because criminals cover up
their crimes and it's the media's fault
this is classic conspiracy theory
circular reasoning where the conclusion
is assumed to be true and if there's
evidence that contradicts it it's
dismissed as part of the cover-up if
there's a lack of evidence that
contradicts it it's dismissed as part of
the cover-up example Q Anon right none
of the Q Anon predictions have come true
that would seem to suggest Q Anon isn't
credible
debunks The Conspiracy Theory right
wrong q and unbelievers believe that the
media is simply not reporting that Q's
predictions have come true
and therefore Q is right because the
media is lying by not reporting how Q's
predictions have come true oh well hard
to argue with that right because it's an
indefeasible statement so how do you
deal with this I don't know how do we
prevent people from falling into this
this trap there's not a simple answer
conspiracy theories
are extraordinarily complex and we've
had so many interviews about that
there's a psychological component social
cultural there's a political Dimension
and there isn't a one-size-fits-all kind
of solution
to disabusing people of conspiracy
theories particularly lack of evidence
is part of the evidence so
it's like a broken record we need to
educate people in critical thinking how
to evaluate a source of information
understand whether a statement being
made is a statement a fact or a
statement of opinion what is evidence
and what is speculation what is accepted
science and what is pseudoscience all of
that we need to engage with the
conspiracy theorists respectfully and
empathetically which I understand is
really tough to do because many of their
ideas are certainly worthy of being
mocked and then third we we need to
create an environment we're abandoning
these conspiracy theories is welcomed
rather than I told you you were an idiot
we need to make the environment where
you abandon the conspiracy theory a
welcoming one where it's like it's so
great that you came to this conclusion I
think this is great and you know
honestly having done this you'll
probably be less likely to fall for
stuff like this in the future that sort
of thing
but it it is not an easy task and when
even on Fox news they are getting to you
seem to kind of be lacking evidence here
you know that there is absolutely
nothing there and that is abundantly
clear at this point in time